ladies and gentlemen good morning
we come together this morning following
the passing of our late sovereign queen
elizabeth ii
our sadness at this time is shared by
people across the globe
as we remember with affection and
gratitude
the lifetime of service given by our
longest reigning monarch
but the basis on which our monarchy is
built has ensured that through the
centuries the crown has passed in an
unbroken line of succession
today's ceremony marks the formal
proclamation to the people of the
district of cambridge of the beginning
of our new king's reign
the day before yesterday the accession
council met at some james's palace to
proclaim our new sovereign
the flags which had flown at half-mast
since the queen's death
were raised briefly to their full height
to mark the start of his majesty's rape
the accession council also made an order
requiring high sheriffs to cause the
proclamation to be read in the areas of
their jurisdiction
the high sheriff of devon discharged
that duty yesterday
and now with my humble duty i bring the
words of the proclamation to the
residents of the district of patina
whereas it has pleased almighty god to
call to his mercy our late sovereign
lady queen elizabeth ii
of blessed and glorious memory
by whose
the crown of the united kingdom of great
britain and northern ireland
is solely and rightfully come to the
prince charles philip arthur george
we
therefore the lord spiritual and
temporal of this realm
and members of the house of commons
together with other members of her late
majesty's privy council and
representatives of the realms and
territories
aldermen and citizens of london and
others
do now hereby with one voice and consent
of tongue and heart
publish and proclaim
that the prince charles philip arthur
george is now
by the death of our late sovereign of
happy memory
become our only lawful and rightful
liege lord
charles iii
by the grace of god of the united
kingdom of great britain and northern
ireland and of his other realms and
territories king
head of the commonwealth
defender of the faith
to whom we do acknowledge all faith and
obedience with humble affection
beseeching by god by whom kings and
queens do reign
to bless his majesty with long and happy
years to reign over us
given james's palace this 10th day of
september in the year of our lord 2022.
god save the king
again
three cheers for king charles iii
hip
hip hip